ce week end les moutons mérinos
côtoyaient des livres le premier salon
national de rambouillet rassemblé 70
auteurs autour de l'histoire c'est le
fil conducteur histoire avec un grand h
et histoire avec un petit h et au
pluriel histoire motive beaucoup
l'histoire et l'histoire au sens large
l'histoire un peu vus par des
universitaires cdr pur et dur mais
également de l'histoire accessible au
grand public et donc le roman historique
également rendre la culture la
littérature accessible à tous en faisant
rencontrer les lecteurs et auteurs
qu'ils soient historien romancier ou
passionnés comme philippe torreton
invité d'honneur c'est un moment de
convivialité comme ça de partage avec
les gens j'ai c'est important je trouve
ça ça permet aussi d'avoir une à
l'occasion de tables rondes ou de
petites conférences ou deux voilà deux
de parler de montrer que la littérature
c'est de cesser fait pour nous l'objet
de mon livre funky ou shakespeare c'est
ça c'est de dire que c'est cet auteur
écrit pour nous nous tous pas seulement
pour une élite pas seulement pour des
gens de théâtre
ça s'adresse à tout le monde ce salon du
livre était aussi l'occasion de
découvrir les métiers du livre comme
celui d'eric poil peau et les relieurs à
montfort l'amaury
et moi je vois j'étais installé à
rambouillet pendant pas mal d'années
j'ai rencontré ici des gens qui
se demander si je n'avais pas disparu
par exemple donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal
et puis je vois les beaucoup des jeunes
sont intéressés par nos métiers
parce qu'ils n'ont jamais vue ils
souvent ils n'ont même pas idée qui a
passé près de quinze mille personnes ont
fait le déplacement sur ce salon